- [Interviewer] Alright,
Gwendolyn.
- Hi?
- [Interviewer] Gwendolyn,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
Originally?
- I am from a small farming town,
in upstate New York,
called Red Hook.
It's a very small town.
I graduated with only about a 100 kids.
- [Interviewer] But tell
me about your childhood.
Did you have both your parents growing up?
- Yeah.
I grew up with my mom,
my dad,
my sister.
My, well...
My older sister,
my older brother
and then my younger sister.
And my,
childhood honestly,
it wasn't that great.
My mom was an abusive alcoholic.
She would,
you know,
physically,
abuse her children,
And,
and she was very,
verbally and
emotionally abusive towards us.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So,
what kind of stuff would she get into?
Just-
- She would throw things a lot.
You known if we like got...
I mean, we were kids,
but like,
even if we like,
spilled a glass of milk
she would like automatically
start throwing things at us
and like punching us in the face
and,
that kind of stuff.
She was very verbally
abusive when I was a teenager
she would tell me that
I'm fat,
I'm a loser,
I'm a horrible person.
And,
just,
it was,
the worst years of my life.
- [Interviewer] So,
you, you left home at what age?
- When I was 18,
I left home
and I actually...
I lived in my car in Woodstock,
New York.
And kind of just,
hung out there for the summer.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Excuse me?
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- I was very
shy.
Had a lot of social anxiety,
and making friends and stuff.
I was kind of the outcast,
or like the loner in high school.
- [Interviewer] And where's
your life taking you,
since, since back then?
- Honestly, I...
My life, since,
you know,
when I left home at 18, it just got...
I mean,
it's gotten worse,
but it's also gotten better.
You know.
As you know,
a transgender woman,
it's really...
You know,
I face a lot of discrimination,
as a lot of places...
And,
you know,
discrimination from my parents
and my siblings,
and people from my school.
And I,
you know,
I turned to drugs and
alcohol for the answer.
And it took me into a very dark place,
that I thought I would never get out of.
But,
eventually,
about three months ago,
I was able to get out of that,
and live a happy and sober life.
- [Interviewer] Are you finding,
life as a transgender
is easier
on the West coast than it is...
- Absolutely!
- [Interviewer] Than it is...
- Yeah.
- I lived in California
about four years ago,
which is part of why ,
I wanted to
leave New York and go
to a treatment facility
that was in California,
because I ...
It was,
the atmosphere was just so much more
friendly and pleasant
- [Interviewer] or accepting.
- Accepting.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] And,
are drugs a part of the picture for you?
- Not anymore.
Since then,
I,
you know,
I've been sober
from alcohol,
and heroin
for about three months now.
- [Interviewer] Where are you living now?
- I live in a sober house.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Mmh.
- [Interviewer] And how
do you support yourself?
- Right now,
my parents had a trust fund set up for me.
So I'm using money from that
until I can get a job,
which is very hard
with everything going on right now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So...
That was a tough time for everybody.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have you
had rough experiences,
being transgender?
People would...
- I have, yes.
You know,
just like the discrimination
of like just things.
People walking down the street say to me,
or like,
you know,
not getting jobs,
or,
I remember,
even like in high school,
I faced a lot of discrimination.
Even from teachers,
and students.
And,
you know,
there's rehabs treatments...
Rehab centers that I've been to,
where I had to,
face discrimination,
even from a place that was
supposed to be helping me,
but discriminated against me,
instead.
and you know I was very...
It's been very difficult.
You know.
But I've learned to,
love myself.
So,
you know.
Whenever I do happen
to face discrimination,
I just let it go
because I know that,
I'm,
I'm just a better person.
And that it doesn't matter what
other people say about you.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
That's gotta be a real challenge.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's nice to hear.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about
the tattoo on your forehead.
- [Gwendolyn] I was homeless
in Denver, Colorado,
in 2018.
And I was friends,
with these other two homeless guys
and I was drinking
and doing a lot of heroin.
And I got drunK,
and I passed out.
And I woke up with the
tattoo on my forehead
that says 'tranny,'
that was done with the sewing.
At the time,
I really wasn't upset about it,
because I was like,
it doesn't really matter.
I'm homeless ,
and doing drugs.
No one's going to care.
But,
now it really bothers me.
Really bothers me.
It's really hard to find a job.
I have to constantly
keep covering it with,
you know, makeup.
And you know,
people in public asking me what it says,
like just random strangers on the street
just asking me like,
"Oh, what's on your forehead?"
And then staring at my forehead,
like,
it really bothers me.
And you know,
I'm going to get it removed.
You know, I haven't had it removed yet
because I was still actively using.
And,
you know,
when you're actively using
you don't really,
care much about yourself.
But,
I would like to see...
I'm going to get it removed.
So I already have like,
looked up some places,
that do tattoo removal,
that are opening right now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What, what are the...
what have been
the most helpful things,
that you've done,
to help your self worth?
Your self image?
- I did a lot of,
positive affirmations.
You know,
just telling yourself
that like you're beautiful,
and that you're worth it.
- [Interviewer] Did you find that,
it's almost like brainwashing
yourself to believe it.
Right?
- Yeah!
- [Interviewer] It's helpful.
- It's like,
I was brain washed for so long,
to think that I'm a fat loser.
- [Interviewer] Exactly.
- So I just did the opposite.
- [Interviewer] It's exactly
- And told myself
that I was beautiful
and lovable.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- A lot of...
I went to a lot of therapy,
to work on,
you know,
my self esteem.
And,
It took a while for me
to realize
that it doesn't matter what
other people say about me.
You know.
I'm my own person
and I should be happy with that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And how old are you?
- I'm 23.
- [Interviewer] 23.
So you're still very young.
- Mmh.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I'm proud of you.
- [Interviewer] It's a lot to go through.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- Yes.
I'm friends with
the girls that are in my sober house.
I didn't really have
friends in high school.
Just because I was very shy and,
didn't know really know
how to talk to people
with being so uncomfortable
in your own body.
So,
but you really have,
some really nice friends in sober living.
- [Interviewer] And what is,
you know, you're only 23,
but what lessons have you learned,
from living?
You've been on the street for how long?
- On and off for five
years but mostly at home.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And you've been treated badly,
and it sounds like sometimes...
What lessons have you learned?
About others?
About people?
- To never give up,
as much as it seems like it's
never going to get better.
Like,
after all the stuff that I've gone through
and I thought that it
would never ever end,
but,
there's always some point
it will end.
And it will get better.
And you can have a happy
and fulfilling life.
- [Interviewer] Do you
find your family is helpful
or supportive at this point?
They're giving you money,
which is good.
- My siblings are really supportive.
My younger sister,
she's a lesbian
and she's very supportive.
My older sister and older brother.
He's very supportive.
The only people
that aren't really that supportive
or my parents,
They tolerate it,
but they don't accept it.
Like,
they won't even talk about it with me.
But I kind of...
I don't let that bother me though,
because you know what,
just,
they don't have to,
you know,
accept me,
as long as I accept me.
- [Interviewer] Exactly.
That's across the board
for everybody, I think.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Awesome.
Well, Gwendolyn,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Yeah. Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Very, very
interesting talking with you.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You're welcome.